[Music]
[Applause]
gabe um this is ann jobs and horses
sounds delicious oh my god
can you even imagine can you even
imagine
that uh why elon musk would be going so
crazy on social media and and pretending
to buy twitter for months and months
after he
you know it's i would i would imagine
and elon musk has known about this
business insider story for some time
i mean he didn't know no i mean i
messaged you yesterday i was like you
cannot convince me
otherwise that my new theory
is that he attempted to buy twitter
to suppress
any
out uh any outlet that was going to
spread the business insider
story right well anyways because he
keeps saying freedom of speech freedom
of speech and it's the exact opposite
what he's trying to do right it's
projection from these end cells
oh my god it's just it's not surprising
but i'm telling you right now
my new theory and you can't convince me
otherwise i said this whole thing
this whole thing uh he's gonna lose a
billion dollars set up
by
his unwanted desire
for
that story to break right and here's the
thing even in that story
they they allow him business insider
said hey we're running this story right
and he said oh it's just a political hit
job they're coming after me and they
said okay fine you know what we will
extend the the amount of time that you
can come back with a with a formal
response if you want but the thing is is
even even in his public statement so far
with on twitter where he's rage tweeting
about how it's you know it's just out to
get him
he's not denying it
he's not denying it no no no he hasn't
denied it because he can't because
there's apparently an nda which prop
more than likely he can't confirm or
deny it in the nba and that's one thing
everyone's debating this morning about
ndas and you know all this [ __ ] well the
thing the thing that happened is she
signed an nda so she feels also at risk
for her own safety that she can't come
forward but it was only a week after or
so that our governor here in california
uh jerry brown
signed a law that's right at the time
because
this was in 2018 or 19. yeah the
incident happened in 2016. okay
the out-of-court settlement that they
agreed on was done in 2018 and she had
to sign paperwork and the following week
this nda law that basically said you
could you you can't be confined to an
nda in the state of california right
which is india's are [ __ ] ridiculous
yeah basically what ndas are doing um is
affording rich powerful white men to
control other people's liberty and their
rights and their freedom and
it is it is hilarious that elon musk is
on twitter today yelling and screaming
about freedom of speech and he's really
upset and i bet i almost bet up
45 billion dollars that that
[ __ ] sues for her freedom of
speech because she she she went against
the nba
and he's not for freedom of speech folks
he's not he's a [ __ ] liar
he's a liar he's a [ __ ] creep
i've got a uh i
decided yesterday i'm gonna do a little
video on elon that breaks down
you know a quick breakdown of the story
as a quick breakdown of his kind of his
history
uh and jobs and horsies break down dude
sanchez the elon musk
saga right just you know jobs and horses
you know we for weeks we've been saying
that elon was never gonna own twitter
which he's not he's not going on twitter
and i'm actually i'm actually going to
predict right here that i would say
within the next 90 days he's not the ceo
of tesla um that i i'm going to predict
right here i'm telling you right now in
my cr in my tony michael's crystal ball
and you can [ __ ] tweet at me when it
comes true in the news breaks that he's
no longer the ceo he'll say something
like well i'm really gonna concentrate
on pretending to buy twitter and i'm
leaving as the ceo and i'm not being
fired it's not that's not and it's not
because i'm a creep and i get my wiener
out in front of our employees um that's
not why that has nothing to do with it
there's nothing i will neither confirm
nor deny the allegations that uh have
you ever listened to him talk the word
cell salad that he is yeah yeah it's uh
yeah i can tell we'll probably get we'll
probably get to it a little bit right
the other thing i want to point out here
is that elon musk says that every minute
of his thinking
makes tesla one million dollars
how much time
i mean if that's not overcompensated for
something but you know whatever oh my
god this this guy's such a dumb [ __ ]
that he think that he he makes he tries
to make us believe that he's some kind
of intelligent he's like listen guys i'm
an einstein i'm a genius i'm going to
advance
civilization
to the next frontier right right and
he's someone that says his thinking
alone
makes the company one million dollar one
million dollars every all the thing he
does per minute makes them one million
dollars right
so then i have to ask
how much time
is this guy spending [ __ ] tweeting
and then
he makes a tweet that says i'm actually
spending less than five percent of my
daily time
tweeting about this stuff i'm running
tesla
bull
[ __ ] right [ __ ] and the people at
tesla know this
elon's got the door shut it says
do not disturb come back tomorrow
doesn't even get out of his mom's
basement i'll prove it to you
but look here look here's our
contestants this week because let's
because i want to get back to elon
because i really want to spend a good
amount of time here [ __ ] just railing
on elon and piling horseshit right on
top of him um you know i really want to
make it bonerific if you want to call it
that year um the contestants were elon
musk representative madison cawthorne
and george w bush i want to start um
here's the uh
here's the the faces the faces of the
week um but george w bush and i don't
know what the youtube poll here's the
twitter poll the numbers on the twitter
the twitter poll in the youtube poll
almost were identical really it was like
59
and then it was like
it was like 60 and then 20 then 20
right so first off i do want to i do
want to bring up
um
oh the george w bush
gaff or whatever the [ __ ] you want to
call it really i don't think it's much
of a gap as much as he's again
projecting yeah but it is kind of gross
because he's making this joke about
iraq and ukraine and he and he kind of
does this thing when
a lot of americans lost their lives over
those decisions that were made 20 years
right right 20 years right made a
decision about wmds that really wasn't
about wmds
dick cheney
george bush going in there for an
unnecessary war making making
assumptions about oh iraq and saddam
hussein and this and that and this is
really the cause and they come back and
they go
okay actually we didn't find it in wmds
uh we actually found out there was no
connection
but since we're here we might as well
just
kind of set up camp for the next couple
decades and uh
and see how it goes right kill thousands
of american lives thousands of american
life
even more innocent lives in the middle
east
let's let's listen to this this
this ridiculous fortion slip here
prisoners are otherwise eliminated from
participating in the electoral process
the result is an absence of checks and
balances in russia
and
the decision of one man
to launch a wholly unjustified
and brutal invasion of iraq
whoosh
whoosh we played this earlier this week
but whoosh he's trying to make the case
that we should you know tamp down
dictators and tamp down fascism in this
and then in the world and promote
democracy and not be [ __ ] murdering
people with war crimes and here he is
with the freudian slip one dude in a
holy war
against against another another region
of the world
um committing committing war crimes in
iraq now let's let's listen to his
little
chuckle after i mean i'll be ukraine
all right anyway
yeah rack two yeah rack two yeah that
that too i i did that you know and again
everyone in that room laughs i mean
they're all [ __ ] probably
the people that were you know involved
in the decision or those who supported
the decision and said yeah well [ __ ]
them we're not over there so whatever
right who gives a [ __ ] who gives a rat's
ass
about what happens
over there to those brown peoples
because that's the rub and then it's the
same thing with the fascist party now
they're they're they're over
they're over in hungary they're
so overtly fascist in this country that
they're running to other countries other
fascist countries to be welcome
i mean they can't even hold a [ __ ]
rally here anywhere but a [ __ ] corn
field a goddamn livestock field a pig a
pigsty yeah because they can't afford to
have a rally anywhere no one will have
them they got to go to hungary jesus
[ __ ] christ
speaking of fascist uh the other the
other
uh nazi on our list
madison cawthorne gabe what what was the
uh what's the thing
what's the reason why we put madison
gothorn
on the list this well
the reason we put madison cough on the
list is not only did he lose the primary
uh which was funny um
you know
but
ask watch over here yeah uh decided to
release
some posts after his loss you know after
which by the way he conceded which i
thought was very interesting because you
know not trying to stop the steal
seemed very unpatriotic of him that
would totally feel within his wheelhouse
to say i don't accept the outcome of the
election or the primary and i want to
fight this
but
fast forwarding to yesterday he releases
a facebook post where he calls out all
of these america first patriots he has a
list here uh from anywhere from tucker
carlson to martial taylor greene to the
great charlie kirk or sorry i mean the
great charlie kirk uh steve bannon yeah
it's just really you know what's funny
about this list is you go back to the
charlie kirk thing like he's so he's so
great that he couldn't even capitalize
the g right or he put you know a period
after wendy rogers whoever this joe guy
period is you know you look at this he
makes a list uh he's like all right i'm
gonna put some text on this uh this uh
this kind of tattered american flag uh
this is gonna be great cool cool okay
now i'm gonna write this post and he
writes this [ __ ]
diatribe post of like
establishment turn their guns on me when
the uniparty coalesced to defeat an
american first member very few people
had my back and then he goes on to talk
about these dumb [ __ ] pro fascist
people on the list here where he goes
you know he actually made a typo and it
used to say
um the time for gentile politics as
usual has come to an end
what he meant to say was genteel but of
course you know i think he might have
had a freudian slip there as well and
can kind of confess his own his own
viewpoints right but he says it's time
for dark magga to truly take command
and then that's where you see yesterday
all throughout twitter it's trending
dark magga so
dark manga dark manga was trending uh
several weeks ago right because it was
ultra magnet then it was magic exactly
and i joked about this too yesterday is
like pokemon it's like ultra mega dark
maga you know they're just leveling up
you know pokemon gotta catch em all
right or you know
gotta fascist them all um but yesterday
so to give context to what's going on
here what i feel like tony's gonna set
it up here is we made a little video
yesterday yeah tony and i got on a call
at 1pm and we've seen this statement yes
we see this statement but we're also
supposed to have a completely different
conversation right we're supposed to be
planning how we want to set up the
january 6th hearings that are going to
be premiering we didn't do any of that
we didn't do any of that so what happens
is i say
did you see this dark maggot thing
that's trending from madison hawthorne
and tony's like no i didn't see that and
i was like hold on let's pull it up so
we read this thing and we're like oh
[ __ ] we got to jump on this because dark
maggots trending has already got like
eight or nine thousand tweets about it
we gotta really get on this
you know kind of similar way that
madison cawthran was really getting on
his cousin in a hotel room right right
so
so tony goes
he he goes really giving it a good hump
really yeah really you know thrusting
his way
into the trends you know yeah you you
can't just elbow your way in there you
gotta you gotta really gotta really you
really gotta get in there right so as
we're talking tony goes oh we should
remake the video with uh darth vader's
head moving and yeah on the ass yeah
instead of madison and i was like yeah
we could do that
with the music with the music because
that was kind of my first idea like
let's put darth vader's uh head on his
ass and do the dun dun dun dun dun
exactly you know and then yeah and then
i was like oh well i was like he's he's
gonna go out of sync like i can't match
up the beat to be like the helmet going
you know with the same threat it's gonna
take way too long it's gonna take way
too long and i was like we gotta get
this video out so then i was like oh you
know what this whole [ __ ] long
diatribe that it goes on
is
it should be
the intro sequence to star wars right
because dark manga reminds you of like
darth vader and the dark yeah yeah the
dark side and right so we're playing
with it and i was like all right i got
to figure out how to make this like uh
this title sequence you know and then i
was like oh it's gonna be called dark
mega the rise of cawthorne and then
basically which is great some people are
like oh you're oh you're so bad because
you're like yes we we were saying we
were making fun exactly making fun of
him so we made a little video and tony
if you want to pull that out yeah we're
going to play it but here's here's the
issue is um
you're going to see it live here now you
can go to the youtube channel and see it
all on its own but when when they
actually youtube has already cut one or
yesterday's video up i'm not sure why we
gotta go oh right yeah yeah but but
they're gonna they're gonna cut out this
part and say that we have to cut this
out of the the video right right um but
here is
here's the world live premiere i guess
of
the rise
the rise
of corn
[Music]
course we do not own any of the the
music yeah i would like to call of
george lucas be like hey listen we use
your music but it was done
in a very i really thought about
artistic ways
i thought about your [ __ ] yeah
yeah and see we're gonna here's the
thing
uh
you know they're like be careful not to
get hyper we're gonna get one we're
gonna yeah we're gonna get a gabriel
yeah
so what will what we'll do is it'll
probably show the video but we'll be
able to cut the music out of the episode
when you're watching on youtube yeah
yeah set up set up spotify play the song
right or play it on youtube we've got
we've got the video up on youtube yeah
yeah yeah yeah because we put it all on
its own uh it can't be monetized it
really isn't pushed in algorithms and we
put it at the top of the our actual
youtube page right so you can go there
and you can actually see it you can
listen to it yeah um but you know it's
it so again we had a call at what
week we we had a conversation yesterday
at 1 pm and we're like all right let's
let's figure out the you know the
schedule if we can yeah and what we're
going to do
and then this thing happened
and then we were probably on the call
for like a couple hours we were like
testing it we were talking about other
stuff as well but we were basically i
was like as i was editing the video and
like testing like all right this is the
this is the current version all right
i'm going to make some tweaks here to
make the sound sync up right and right
you know the other thing too is we were
trying to figure out the payoff because
right i didn't know if the payoff should
be the cousin humping video right or if
it should be the tree punching video we
were we went with the tree punching
because when you when you put the music
to it it really it seemed to does it
just naturally synced up right and
obviously just like he was playing it
it's almost like he was yeah
[Music]
so when you watch it on the on the
podcast here there might be a delay so
if you go into youtube then you'll get
the official go check it out
you know
unsynced version right don't forget to
subscribe to the youtube channel because
it's important because we are going to
post more uh satire and parody videos
um and you know clowning you son of a
[ __ ] so don't forget to subscribe
while you're there over on youtube and
you need to search it at the top of
youtube the tony michaels but if you're
on uh mine to such facebook page we
simulcast there the link is at the top
there and you can subscribe there as
well
minus marky says these calls should be
pay-per-view you'll be rich i'm sure
without a doubt the calls are very
entertaining now whether people actually
want to listen on them i don't know
maybe maybe we'll start doing like we
can community like we'll have like calls
where we chat with people maybe you know
we know we we've got there's a there's a
youtube membership now um it's kind of
like patreon and we we turned it on we
haven't really talked about it much but
maybe that's one of the things that we
that we do is we let we let people in on
our creative meetings that we have our
our zoom type calls we let them in just
uh just to peek in like we'll record
them and post them privately and then
you can watch right right right right
you know what you can watch the creative
process happen just don't steal our
ideas because what we well i mean we can
do it after we can like right
and then
i've said something or tony has said
something and then someone on twitter
goes and says that's good and then they
take it and then i'm like well great now
i can't do this thing that i was joking
about right right
margie uh thanks for the super chat she
says we are on and we need no doubt
t-shirts oh they need to oh doubt no
doubt doubt me help me doubt me t-shirts
yeah maybe we'll maybe we'll work on
some doubt me t-shirts for you guys or
doubt me hats yeah um yeah yeah that
sounds like a good idea maybe i have a
crystal ball or something i don't know
yeah we'll see maybe i'm really not a
bra it just says
right right i'm not i'm not a prophet
really it's just it's just i i can see
what these where the the minds of these
[ __ ] lunatics go
yeah and well there is a i do want to
bring up something once we get to elon
mm-hmm about uh lunatics no no i was
going to be like predicting predicting
the in the future the play that he has
yeah well speaking of lunatics you put
uh you put marjorie tay they're green
as dishonorable what was the reason why
you decided fake outrage the fact that
she and other people like marjory t uh
like lauren bobert oh you mean the baby
formula thing yeah the baby not only the
baby formula but it's also any time
there is any sort of quote unquote
crisis happening whether it's gas crisis
and we need to alleviate and fix the
situation or it's a baby formula crisis
because the fda [ __ ] up and they you
know did not actually act on it soon
enough and now that they're they are
acting on it in terms of shutting down
the plant that makes the baby formula to
make sure that it is okay for babies to
take and no more babies die because of
course the republicans are pro-life and
they want babies to live right
wrong it is really kind of weird though
because yesterday
um i had someone down in the comments of
a of a clip i posted about pro starvers
and they were like oh did you even did
you even [ __ ] read why i'm like look
if you read the reason why they're
saying what what the [ __ ] fascists
are saying who hate government
regulation are saying there wasn't
enough government regulation and now
that we want more government regulation
we're not willing to do it to make sure
it's it's a bunch of [ __ ] tripping
over their own feet let's watch here's
here's here's
marjorie foot green on trader tv
american sunrise
i'm kind of [ __ ] like a good morning
america likes i don't know
how are you supposed to know what these
[ __ ] weirdos yeah let's let's watch
let's watch what she says
they broke our country and it's very
difficult to get it back on track but
here's the real deal
she's gonna tell us wait who broke the
country i don't i right we're not not
physically broke doors and windows yeah
not the people that broke broke in right
and tried to overthrow the government
not those people right they didn't they
didn't try to break democracy and and
just the foundation that this country's
built on got it just want to make sure
just want to make sure they were giving
[ __ ] tours of the capital of which
windows to break and which doors to
break down for crying out loud [ __ ]
jesus
franklin stone dress she is wearing a
fred flintstone oh my god you know the
last time i saw that much of a print on
a on a piece of clothing was tiger king
tiger king oh yeah maybe she's the
leopard king yeah um
[ __ ] marjorie her foot green let's
let's continue with the crazy here
explain some of the other problems oh
yeah explain just a government program
wick is a problem gabe wick do you know
what wick is yes what is wick do you
know what wick is yeah yeah yeah
wick is the the program that allows uh
these safe
these safe
what is this so here's what happens with
substance here's what happens with wick
when a woman
finds out she's pregnant
it is it is a government program for
poor
women
and poor children to receive nutrition
while she is pregnant now
i don't know about you
but there's this book
it may or may not be called the bible
okay and there's this guy in the second
half of the [ __ ] book
where
you know he would make sure people were
fed
right it was kind of like a core belief
that people should have nutrition and
[ __ ]
now
she's saying wic is bad and listen to
why she says wic is bad here it's the
government program listen to why she
says it's bad the government program is
is the largest buyer the largest
customer for baby formula in the united
states of america the reason why wic
is the largest
buyer
a baby formula in this country
is because
half
almost half of all baby formula
is paid for by wic
because half the [ __ ] baby formula
that is bought
is a people who are low income
i still don't understand what she's
talking about here because she acts like
the government is buying
baby formula so no one else has it
listen to what her explanation is it's
really [ __ ] wacky
and now joe biden and his administration
they're moving into their solution is
making wick an even bigger customer yeah
all baby formula everywhere all baby a
formula everywhere we should provide it
to anyone who doesn't have it that's
what we should do like that's i mean you
would assume you would assume they're
like hey listen i want to make sure that
i'm giving the proper nutrition or the
the supplemental nutrition through baby
formula for
women and children right you would want
it you would you would assume
that a pro-life group would say yeah we
want to make sure that you have the
right uh supplements and and different
uh substances and and and and
um and nutrition
for for for women
infants children low income especially
so if you restrict that
from those people
then
what do we what are we doing here guys
like if if we're taking it away and
we're trying to make it more scarce how
are we helping the people that it's
originally supposed to be intended for
one of the most successful
programs that has come from
the bills that were passed for
coronavirus relief one of the most
successful programs gabe
was the program that allows all children
no matter your your age no matter what
grade you're in no matter how rich or
poor your parents are to get school
lunch
for free
we as a government are paying for all
now it's gonna it's gonna expire which
we should not let it expire we should
not let this school lunch part of our
education expire
part of education in this country should
be us as a government providing children
food while they're in a government
building and they're being taught and
they have public education that should
be our responsibility and i say tax the
absolute [ __ ] out of the horse [ __ ]
guy attacks the [ __ ] out of him to pay
for it tax the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of him
to pay for it and also i believe that
all children everywhere
who use formula if they're not
breastfeeding and they're using formula
they should be able to be provided that
nutrition as well that's how pro-life i
am that's how pro-nutrition i am that
sounds pretty radical dude sounds very
radical [ __ ] bunkers that we can't
get on the same page as to make sure
that children and babies aren't [ __ ]
starving no matter how rich or poor
their [ __ ] parents are this is
ridiculous
when in reality many of the parents that
can't buy buy baby formula for their
baby they're not on the wic program and
the wic program is making it more
difficult for them to buy baby formula
so what she's saying is oh the woes of
the rich people the rich white people in
this country go to the grocery store and
there's no baby formula there because
the people on wic take up all the
formula because all the poor people are
buying formula are you seeing what she's
saying she's saying poor babies should
starve
but the other the other thing that i'm
hearing from this right now is that
margery taylor greene is making the case
that we have too many people right who
are low-income and cannot afford right
we have created a country and a society
where people are not able to raise the
children that you may or may not try to
force the women to have but they live in
a low income situation so then you say
well there's too many of these people
that are taking the resources and what
are we going to do
people what are you going to do with too
many of them right exactly
so it's like you look at that and you're
like
now now let's let's let's take this one
step further and say we live in a world
where they force
women to have babies it becomes illegal
to have abortions and you have to raise
what they're gonna do now what happens
if you have even more people who are
unable to raise a child
on one job they have to take multiple
jobs they're low income they don't have
the resources the support or any sort of
uh
groups or clinics that they can go to to
get education or to get other kinds of
supplements or or
resources you know such as like baby
formula
what happens then there's going to be
more people who would be dependent on
wic
yeah well paula
she she asked a good question here
because she actually she actually does a
reverse explanation of this she does a
projection explanation of this um paul
asks don't you have to have a wic
voucher in a store where there is no
value for anyone right so like if
someone goes in the store you either
have cash to buy baby farm there or you
have a wick voucher which is like cash
because what the store does is they if
they're a wick participant right just
like ebt
right exactly they take they take the
wick voucher and then they cash the wick
voucher and the government sends them
the money for that voucher it's like a
it's like a check from the government
yeah at the grocery store has to cash
right and that's what the voucher is but
listen listen bola to her explanation
here
because if you're on wic if if you're a
uh you know someone that needs to be on
that government assistance you're
allowed to buy as much baby formula as
you want to
with your wick vouchers that's not true
you only have so much voucher and your
voucher is based on how many children
you have eating baby formula this is
really [ __ ] stupid she's basically
saying that poor this is the stupid
thing that they do when they're like oh
poor people are buying lobster and they
have refrigerators like this is the dumb
[ __ ] that they do like poor people are
buying up all the [ __ ] formula so
rich white people don't have it that's
what she's that's what she's sending
into the universe here it seems like
there's also projection happening here
absolutely like
who would be who like you got to look at
this too it's like you're assuming that
someone who is already low income would
have the means to store an
abundant amount of baby formula like
they're hoarding that [ __ ] right right
oh i'm hoarding i'm just going to go
sell it on the street babies aren't
eating what's happening but if you're a
rich person that has the means and the
resources and also
the storage space let's say right you
might be that person who could either
buy it or you send someone else in to go
buy it let's see this with ammo they do
it with ammo exactly so you have the
situation where it's like the people
that are actually
buying up all the baby formula the
people who are
who the same thing happens when when you
know like when the pandemic happens like
oh [ __ ] we gotta buy up stuff we gotta
we gotta we gotta stock up on all this
like who are the people that are able to
buy a large amount of items right
but apollo makes good points she says
it's not an endless supply of loaded
cash on a card voucher that's right they
only have they only they only get so
many vouchers in a certain period of
time based on the child or children that
they have and that's how they actually
go to the grocery store and use the
voucher to buy the formula people who
have cash aren't now they're restricted
right now because there's a restricted
supply but likely that there's a big
restricted supply because people who had
the cash to buy the [ __ ] were going in
the grocery store and buying carts and
carts and carts of the stuff so poor
people who have vouchers can't buy it
she's a [ __ ] bonehead this [ __ ]
marjorie taylor green is a bonehead you
cannot no matter if you have cash or a
voucher can't buy something that's not
on the shelf that is just
that is just insanity to think that poor
people with vouchers are buying formula
that doesn't exist it's ridiculous and
that's the whole point is the point is
it doesn't matter who's getting the
formula if babies are getting the form
that who need the nutrition that's the
point it shouldn't [ __ ] matter who's
buying it where it's going how the store
shelves are stocked whatever as long as
the babies who need their nutrition are
receiving new nutrition that should be
your [ __ ] goal but this [ __ ]
this skank and this [ __ ] fred
flintstone skank is not seeing the real
picture because she doesn't give a [ __ ]
about babies she doesn't give a [ __ ]
about poor children she doesn't give a
[ __ ] about hungry children she doesn't
give to shits she only cares about what
her [ __ ] little whiteness and her
little white nationalism can sell to
stoke violence and to stop fear and to
stoke kate around this country for poor
brown and black people
that's what she's saying let's finish
what this skank has to say they're
increasing that for those those parents
but if you're not on wic you're limited
in how many uh how many cans of baby
formula you're allowed to buy that's
because there is a shortage you dumb
[ __ ] what
how how and how in the [ __ ] did they go
through covid and the toilet paper
crisis this
again it was a bunch of [ __ ] rich
people going and buying up all the
goddamn toilet paper because they
thought it was gonna be that's what i'm
saying it was like the only people who
are able to afford a large quantity of
items that they want to stock up because
at the end of the world or they're
trying to
trying to to prepare themselves for for
an event that they would not have access
to these things it's rich people you
have a disposable income that means that
you can buy a large quantity that you
can then store in your house that
actually has the space to have it but
not someone who is dependent on the wic
program to use the voucher to purchase
who are limited by the number that they
can do in any given month or period of
time and again she's not just people
yeah she's projecting because she's
saying the people who actually are
limited to the amount that they can buy
because they don't have the money and
they only have the voucher that they can
purchase them that they're the ones who
are limited to how much formula they can
buy someone with cash before the
shortage and before the grocery stores
had to say you can't buy more than what
you [ __ ] need you greedy
[ __ ] with cash that are buying
this [ __ ] and then going out and
reselling it for higher prices you can't
do that before that they could buy as
much as they [ __ ] wanted they could
buy the whole goddamn stock of the store
out this is nonsense it's a [ __ ] lie
and it's all projection
speaking of projectionist um we have the
alpha cuck of the week is tucker carlson
why did why did why did we select i
think i know but why did we select
tucker girls well tucker carlson is the
main reason why uh
our our homeboy as we've we've given him
the name of maggie king mass shooter
he is
he is the teacher for white supremacists
right he is the guiding light
what is it called the white replacement
theory is that what the wrt you don't
gotta you say you should worry about crt
not wrt according to tucker carlson
which they're holy [ __ ] right
when really tucker carlson is saying i
as a white man i'm threatened by those
around me i need to make sure that we
stay in power i need to make sure that
we replace all others so that white
people are the dominant race we are the
superior race we are the race that is
what tucker carlson is trying to
advocate for as well as other people who
are you know part of this pro fascist
group they're trying to push this wrt
white replacement theory
narrative out there to say white people
are the victims they're actually the
ones under attack and in order to make
sure that they're they are not
eliminated
from this world we need to make sure
that we
eliminate others
well you also tweeted a graphic and i it
looks like a screenshot from a broadcast
i don't know if this was the re i know
the white replacement um yeah i want to
get to our winner here soon so i'm going
to transit do one of my tony michaels
transitions here so seamless yeah i know
i know oh
hang on you haven't seen it yet you know
you never know you never it might be
this whole thing was the transition it's
so it's so effortless that right right i
i made sure that gabe made this graphic
and did this tweet that you know 16
hours ago so i can transition right at
this spot
no really there's not that much playing
that goes on um we're we're really not
part of the cabal it's uh it's we're
flying out the state of our past right
now we just throw spaghetti at the wall
and see if it sticks uh gabe says i
think you're quoting tucker here um
and i don't know if he said this on this
broadcast or maybe this is parody but it
seems like he said this for sure did
elon off elon musk offer a horse in
exchange for sex
or is it a coordinated attack by antifa
to stop him from purchasing twitter
maybe maybe not who's to say i'm just
asking questions tucker carlson probably
um here is the uh here's the graph oh
here's the graphic here um if you if you
see the uh this graphic up here in the
top with the elon musk you might
recognize it from today
but it says tucker what's wrong with
hush money and a horse
listen you're you're doing parody here
but there is definitely at some point
where tucker carlson is going to simp
for [ __ ] elon musk and say oh well
this this story this story may not be
true and even if it is true what's wrong
with elon musk whipping out his wiener
and asking for a hand job in exchange
for a horse what i mean what's what's
wrong why do we live in america in a
state of america that you can't just
whip out your erect penis
and rub a woman's leg without consent
isn't it how is this
the world we live in
oh my god when did a white man become
the bully oh i guess these are just
questions that i'm asking because i'm an
inquiring mind right well he's gotta ask
these questions he's gonna ask these
questions especially about our winner
elon musk elon musk
i love the sad face that she got on this
week now let's let's give this
[ __ ] his due for his win
of boner of the week
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god so did you see that the uh let
me see if i can bring it up here um
they're actually i'm sorry i just had to
i would pause
yeah thank you i wish i had a penis
because according to carlson that's
what you have as an inalienable right in
america
well i mean
in you know
uh if you had if you had a penis paula
you could you could trade you could
trade horsies for hand jobs apparently
um so
this elon musk news drops and i said i i
seen this tweet uh
cara
caracara carlson here i'm not sure which
how you pronounce it but which way but
um
she tweeted a screenshot of greg
abbott's where he said elon musk picked
a great state to move to but i want to
show you that here in a second but i
said he just became a republican and
they already had to scrub for elon if
you look at the
the tweet here
so here's elon musk when he said the
attacks against me should be through the
political blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah and and graham is
like yeah you could come here free
speech hand jobs and horses for everyone
probably
here's the thing
almost as soon as the story drops
greg abbott deleted this tweet
so like they're scrubbing the [ __ ] out
of their accounts because they know that
this elon musk stuff is really bad
that's why i'm saying within 90 days
folks my prediction is elon musk will
not be the ceo
he will not be the ceo
of tesla or spacex or wherever the hell
else he's he's a
ceo or whatever i think tess is the one
well uh i mean here here's the thing uh
well i just sent you i just sent you a
tweet this is what i was talking about
earlier
is the thing so april 27th coming here
and now we're at you know almost a month
later but this is not too long after the
agreement went public you know i think
he's maybe a couple days after
and he started to make his first tweet
which kind of put that this is this is
after i even said there's no way this is
going to happen yeah this is after you
said this but this is right after the
deal was this is when the paperwork was
signed the contract went public
and then oh yeah yeah yeah this is when
they started to file the sec stuff that
everyone had to see because it is a
public company exactly so as soon as
that happened and he made his first
tweet that was kind of going after
twitter i was like oh this is weird
because it breaks the rules of behavior
that they had agreed on that they did in
the agreement was
elon musk could not bash executives or
employees of twitter or twitter the
company and twitter could not bash elon
musk that was the agreement because you
have to go in with amicable amicable
kind of
relations and not try to have some sort
of uh
animosity toward each other
especially one that would ruin the deal
or the
um
the the kind of uh value of the company
and so i said what if he's intentionally
doing this because now it's like all
right well you know this is a big money
but my my uh my my prediction here was
like what if he's trying to do is to get
out of the deal and trying to get out of
the 44 billion yeah a billion dollars
plus potential legal fees against him by
twitter is a lot but not something he
couldn't cover in terms of the casualty
that he has on hand versus the 44
billion which he was still unable to
secure and to this day is still on shaky
ground if if it hasn't already been kind
of pulled from under him and so my thing
was saying i was like he's going to play
victim and he's going to blame the left
the woke left for preventing this deal
from happening and as we've seen he
brings in the bots and says the bots are
the problem and then he says i'm going
to be attacked and then he's going to
say oh it's just a political hit job
against me and i'm actually a republican
now but i used to be democrat which is
hilarious you're right right which is
hilarious because according to open
secrets if you look up elon musk you'll
see that he was actively donating to
people like kevin mccarthy and the uh
national republican congressional
committee as well as others while he was
a quote unquote democrat voting democrat
we'll say right he was a liberal as
one of the woke left i guess well here's
here's the thing isn't it kind of weird
that right because he knew this story
was going to drop that right before
isn't it convenient
don't you think that right before this
story drops
this this [ __ ] this [ __ ]
switches to the republican party like
he's like that's
the way of a true republican
is that you've got to
uh you know your attempt to get in front
of it is that you simply say
oh you know this is all made up it's
fake news it's just a hit job so you
project you blame others and you play
the victim that is pl that is the
republican strategy 101 when there is
some sort of controversy that comes out
and so he was like yeah republicans will
love me because i'm going to fit right
in because who is attacking me the woke
left and who do they hate the woke left
and now who's going to ruin this deal
for me the woke left and boom just the
other day it plays out exactly what i
said was the woke life was going to be
the issue he's going to say he's a
republican and that's where he was going
to be feel welcome when it turns out
it's actually a little bit more
layered of the reason because he decided
to whip out his erect penis rub a leg of
a woman who said no and then offer her a
[ __ ] horse
right what normal person offers someone
a horse to say
you want to sex me up right now i'll
give you a horse
nobody nobody that's not annoying
i'll buy you a pony yeah do you want
like a small pony or like a big paw you
want like a real horse this [ __ ] guy
this it ain't no wonder amber heard was
dating this guy okay so maybe
she [ __ ] on something there may musk is
elon musk mother okay and i'm going to
show you a video where he's hedging his
bet on the republican democrat thing
here in a minute that was released
yesterday and i actually surmised that
he was blurring out the
the background of his mom's basement
which i i think is very likely based on
this evidence here this tweet was sent
out i don't know sometime may 18th
this is his mother
based on this account trolling him
here's here's what she says digging
deeper
poor elon is trending which i think poor
elon is trending again today
poor elon is trending this twitter
account has 16 followers
okay
it has over a thousand likes and four
hundred retweets can you believe that
game by people who also have very few
followers one only has seven volleyball
these sound like elon bots these sound
like elon stance
we always have these [ __ ] up in
our tweets and they always got three
followers seven followers you know
two followers zero followers who is
creating these trends and why are they
dishonest and malicious for poor elon
trending get the [ __ ] out of here with
this [ __ ] this tweet sucks and his mom
standing for him
is really on brand for these incels
don't you think he's like mother i am
i i just need to uh send a message uh i
can't do it on my account uh i need to
uh
i need to defend my honor
like that's like so you think elon
tweeted this you don't yeah yeah yeah
why not i mean like this whole thing's
like uh he's like oh people are people
are attacking me um so uh i need to uh
i need to use other accounts uh verified
accounts uh not bots to to to come to my
uh
uh my my uh my savior my saving grace
someone needs to save me i'm the victim
you know right absolutely he's always
the victim he's always a victim in this
video that i if i can find the son of a
[ __ ] uh here once i find it here i'll
show you here
here it is um more perfect union put
this up this is some kind of conference
or some [ __ ] that he's speaking at but
if you look here he's got he's got the
blur
uh feature on if if anyone's never done
like a zoom call or something like that
you can turn a blur feature on where it
blurs the background so they can't see
what the hell is behind you and i'm
guessing this is the reason why he
blurred this is because he's in his
mom's basement you know elon musk
doesn't actually own a house he couch
surfs yeah i mean
i'm in his mother's basement right now
yeah right is she dave is now blurring
he's doing the uh the whole mom's
basement thing
it's great it's great down here we're
getting freaking toasty nose later and
we're getting pop tarts and we're gonna
have some rc cola too
great rc cola this [ __ ] would
drink some rc cola so he's got this
blurred out but listen to what this
bonehead says about republicans and
democrats he really is hedging his bet
here on this story because before before
this video was aired and released the
story hadn't dropped yet but listen to
this and you is this from the same
financial times thing or is this from a
different panel oh let's let's let's
listen and i i would class myself as a
moderate and you know neither republican
nor nor democrat um and in fact uh i
have voted vote overwhelmingly for
democrats uh historically overwhelmingly
like i'm not sure
i might never have voted for a
republican just to be clear right um now
now this election
the democrat party is overly overly
controlled by the unions and by the
trial lawyers particularly the class
action lawyers
so here he's talking about unions right
and we know he's talking about labor
unions because this [ __ ] hates
labor unions yeah because he doesn't
look at that just look at the lawsuits
that are against the factory right
exactly
and well i mean that's the one reason
why you talked about moving to texas
because it's a right to work state where
you don't have to [ __ ] have unions in
your factory right where people can't
unionize to make sure that they're paid
a decent wage to make sure that the
owners of the company aren't [ __ ]
them in the ass over their labor so
let's listen to what he says about you
listen to what he says about unions this
is [ __ ] gross
um and generally if you if you'll see
something that doesn't that is not in
the interest of the of the people um
on the democrat side it's going to come
because of the unions uh which is just
another form of monopoly the unions are
another form of monopoly this guy really
is if this is supposed to be one of the
most intelligent human beings that we're
supposed to have on this
planet this is the guy unions are the
you you're
unions are the ones that look out for
the betterment of the of the workers and
the right they're the ones who are
literally fighting to make sure like we
want to make sure they're compensated
well we want to make sure that they have
the right benefits and hours that
they're you know like unions are the
things that saved us from basically
uh uh you know uh taking advantage of
people for labor well i mean cynthia
points out a good the cynthia rice
points out a good uh
thing here unions built our middle class
like how do you think how do you think
we have the middle class in this country
how do you think people the entire
generation of people built their entire
family wealth on uh the factories and
the unions and the union jobs and the
union work that they had it's like an
idiot i mean of course someone like elon
musk who's you know who's a [ __ ]
billionaire would feel threatened by
a group of people who wanted to
you know come together and say hey
you know we feel like we should have
these rights and the billionaire says
i mean
i mean that means that it's going to
take for my bottom line right and that's
more
or if i have to cut costs here then i'm
not going to be able to give more money
to myself and that just doesn't seem
very fair because like i do a lot of the
work because like i said everyone you
know every minute that i'm thinking
about tesla i'm making him a million
dollars right he's so good the uh the
trial lawyers uh
that that's where actions will be
happening from the democrats side
they're not in the interests of the
people and then um to be fair on the
republican side uh he's hedging his bet
if you say like where does something
like not not ideal happening it's
because of corporate evil and uh
religious zealotry um but that's
generally where the bad things will be
coming from on the republican side um
that are not representative of the
people so
um in in the case of biden he is simply
too too much uh captured by the unions
um which was not the case with obama um
so in the case of obama you could have
you know he was sort of quite reasonable
um and i think he took more of a view of
that you know obviously he'd take the
concerns of the unions into account but
uh there are bigger issues at stake and
and unfortunately
this is supposed to be the most
intelligent human being that we're ever
supposed to see ever ever this is the
person that everyone thinks is a genius
which is a [ __ ] reminder people i
have a friend who works at spacex who is
a literal rocket scientist okay he is a
rocket scientist the guy is a [ __ ]
genius way beyond intelligence that i am
capable of or that i can even register i
have also a friend who works at tesla or
rather worked at tesla and ran marketing
these are people that interacted with
with elon musk and they said gabe give
yourself credit you could be a rocket
surgeon i'm positive of it oh sure yeah
a rocket yeah
rocket surgery rocket surgery so what
did your friend say about elon musk they
said elon musk is a weird guy
and they also said elon musk is not
a genius that everyone makes him out to
be
this guy this guy buys up other people's
intellectual property and runs around
acting like he invented it yep
he is the thomas edison of our day you
know this is the thing that we did this
is the thing that we did in our country
we had this culture where we we we
idolized people like thomas edison who
thomas edison did a lot of good things
for the country but he was not the
inventor of half the [ __ ] right that we
claim that he's inventor of he paid he
paid other people to invent that [ __ ]
under his name this is ridiculous and
that's why that's why we should have
unions that's why we should [ __ ] pay
people for their work and their labor
and their thoughts and their
intellectual property so people like
this [ __ ] can't run around
claiming it's theirs creating wealth off
of it for their entire [ __ ] being and
and being able to pretend to buy a
public company like twitter [ __ ] him
this [ __ ] bonehead [ __ ]
that's what i got to say that's what i
got to say we're running out of time
here um thanks for joining us bonus we
don't forget to follow us on twitter at
tonymichaelspod you can vote there
every single week and also go to the
youtube and subscribe to youtube youtube
channel the tony michaels podcast
because every single friday we will
break down bonehead of the week for you
you can vote on youtube or twitter
for bone of the week don't forget to
watch us every single weekday though
monday through friday
noon eastern eleven seven nine pacific
days a week though seven days a week
that's right bone end of the week is on
the directories
on sundays and on saturdays we do the
best of the week so you will find those
pieces of content there too
but thanks for joining us stick around
we got a few announcements right after
the bone of the week music thank you for
joining us for bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]